welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and quantumania's ending may have
left you feeling a bit left behind like
Scott Lang himself a bit amiss that some
glitch was snuck into this Matrix under
our noses that perhaps we didn't meet
all the gangs we were supposed to and
thanks to Rocket money for sponsoring
today's vid more about them in a minute
I already broke down how Scott's
timeline was probably altered but
perhaps what's weirdest about Quantum
mania's ending is that the more we learn
about it this was clearly a reshoot from
some other alternate ending Cassie's
rushed Rescue of Scott and Hope from the
quantum realm where things stand exactly
with Scott and the Kang Dynasty it all
just feels like there's something
they're not telling us and instead try
to overwhelm us with a screaming crowd
of gangs so that it's too loud to hear
ourselves think really it is the
quietest of kangs I'm most interested to
get to know young Nathaniel Richards AKA
iron lad a young Avenger who rumor has
it was going to be Cassie's silent
partner in this movie's final minutes
but Marvel at the 11th Hour got cold
beep and reshot the ending leaving poor
Young Nathan and as the one well-known
Kang still in a forgotten timeline I'm
gonna break down who this kind variant
is what Marvel Studios plan is is the
Young Avengers canceled and what the
hell really happened with this movie
from a big picture Marvel Studios Disney
point of view also subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive where I did an
insanely detailed look back into Loki
season one and you can support our
growing Network by grabbing some merch
at nerdright.shop like something from
our Deep dive collection okay since
we're talking Kang here let's talk
timeline guanamania was hastily reworked
right up until the last minute according
to the bfx artists who worked on the
film it hasn't been confirmed yet what
the original ending of the movie was but
when the screenwriter was asked if they
ever plan to kill off Scott Lang or some
of the other characters Jeff loveness
confirmed to The Hollywood Reporter that
they did quote game out a ton of
scenarios and they even quote debated
other banishments and imprisonments But
ultimately they didn't want Quantum
media to end too similarly with infinity
war with Thanos and killing off some of
the heroes okay we don't really know how
far the production actually got into any
alternate ending but do know that the
ending we got was shot extremely
recently said photos of Paul Rudd in Los
Angeles dated January 6 2023 only about
two months ago show him with the
Baskin-Robbins cake box outside of
bridge Donuts a shot that we only see at
the end of the movie January 2023 this
would have been six months after the
first trailer footage was shown at Comic
Con in July and three months after the
film's first Goodbye Yellow Brick Road
trailer was released in October and yeah
just one week before that big Modoc
trailer was released in January this new
ending of Scott looping back into his
routine left with the dread of the King
Dynasty was shot real late in production
only about a month before the film's
Hollywood Premiere this isn't like a
goofy bonus post-credit scene tag like
the Shawarma scene and the 2012 Avengers
movie that was shot a week before that
movie's release this whole ending with
Scott on the sidewalk is a crucial
thematic resolution to the film and from
a production standpoint it would be
something that you would shoot on the
same day or two with the intro sequence
scenes since it's all the same locations
in the same actors but we know they
didn't shoot those intro scenes in
January because we already saw that
footage in the trailer back in October
they went to this extra effort to go
back to the same location re costume the
same day players and do all this new
stuff just to prevent some less desired
option this must be a new ending that
replaced something that was there before
so what was that something well again
loveness implied that there were other
endings in which Scott died and or was
left stranded in the quantum realm and
according to some unconfirmed rumors
there was a version of this movie with a
post-credits scene that instead of
Cassie inexplicably using a satellite to
open a rip through Dimensions to rescue
Scott and hope Cassie instead was going
to receive a mystery communication from
some unknown figure to activate a new
Avengers Initiative to save Cassie's
father in other Avengers and thwart Kang
this message would have come from a
friendly Kang variant a young Nathaniel
Richards who fears his future one who
also goes by the name of iron lad half
the fun of the Super Bowl is the ads but
to get that fun looking stuff you gotta
have some money rocket money can help
with that it makes saving money easy
rocket money used to be true bill but
true bill mutated from a bill management
app into a full-on money management
Powerhouse rocket money rocket money
does everything true bill did and more
helping 3.4 million members take control
of their finances with easy to use
features that put you back in charge of
your finances one of Rocket money's best
features is that it helps you find and
cancel all your unwanted subscriptions I
was wasting hundreds of dollars every
month on stuff I didn't even use and now
I can use rocket money's smart savings
account to put that money aside instead
I just choose the amount I want to save
and how frequently rocket money
automatically deposits my money into a
savings fund that I can withdraw from
anytime for the money I'm spending
instead of saving I use the budgeting
tool it monitors my spending by category
sends notifications when I've exceeded
my spending limits and visualizes my
spend to earn ratio by month quarter or
year rocket money can even negotiate
bills from internet service bills to
cable and phone bills I didn't even know
those could be negotiated just upload a
photo of your bill and Rocket money does
the rest once you've signed up you can
unlock even more features in premium
it's so easy to use and there's no
reason not to take control of your
finances to try rocket money out for
free and support our Channel head to
rocketmoney.com new rockstars or click
the link in the video description now
I've mentioned iron lad in a few other
videos but just to summarize he's a 31st
Century Nathaniel Richards who hasn't
yet grown into a multiversal scientist
adult he gets approached by his older
self Kang and ends up in a battle that
sends a kid hurtling back to the present
day where he finds Visions old operating
system with a message to initiate an
Avengers Fail-Safe program Nathaniel
merges with visions Tech which is Stark
hardware and it becomes iron lad founder
of the Young Avengers in this case this
Avengers Fail-Safe message to Cassie
received would finally give an answer to
why Marvel Studios has been introducing
so many second generation younger
Avengers and why so many of the first
generation of injured adults are
off-world or incapacitated in the MCU at
the moment some Avengers are off world
or off reality maybe coming back to find
in King Dynasty or Secret Wars and then
some younger Avengers staying on Earth
to fight the smaller battles but instead
what we got was a wild mid-credit scene
that feels like it was originally going
to be a post-credit scene and then a
post-credit scene that was actually just
a scene from the upcoming season of Loki
which was awesome and great and I loved
it but it also just feels like a ringer
backup contingency plan I think the real
secret truth behind this change can be
found in the big picture happenings at
Marvel Studios parent company Disney so
forgive me as I explained the succession
style media business drama cue the music
[Music]
okay so marble phase four in the era of
MCU Disney plus content in which we've
had roughly three to four series per
year happened under the stewardship of
former Disney CEO Bob chaping last
November Disney surprised many by
announcing that they would be
prematurely ending chapix contract and
bringing back his predecessor the
popular former CEO Bob Iger who stepped
away in early 2020. shaping had come
under Fire for a number of reasons but
Chief among them Disney plus just wasn't
as profitable as expected in its first
two years and the Disney board of
directors feared a proxy battle with
billionaire investor Nelson Peltz so
they panicked and brought back the
Golden Boy Bob Iger a more trusted
leader within the company who could
probably get away with some more
unpopular decisions and so in early
February Iger announced a restructuring
plan that would mean a layoff of 7 000
employees and cutting 5.5 billion in
costs this was enough to appease Peltz
and he backed off and so now every
division owned by Disney is scaling back
its production this includes Marvel
Studios because literally oh week after
this Marblehead Kevin feige did an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
confirming that Marvel would be spacing
out their releases and putting out fewer
shows per year a few days after that
what do you know the Marvels was delayed
from July 2023 to November 2023 and I
think part of this General scaling back
meant that feige had to push his Young
Avengers plan which also meant that
shortly after the past holidays
reshooting the ending of quantumania to
remove iron land and Cassie teaming up
and instead focusing on making sure we
all stayed subscribed to Disney plus
through the end of the fiscal year so we
can see Loki season two and you know
what I'm so goddamn pumped for that show
that I am happy to do my part but what
does this mean for our dear forgotten
young Kang iron lad really I just think
this changes his mission rather than an
immediate newcomer to bridge the Young
Avengers together on Earth for now he's
one of these mystery faces in the crowd
of Kings responsible really only for his
relationship with his dynasty The Horde
perhaps even the one Kang capable of
helping the worst of himself find his
soul and honestly I'm more interested in
that than I am and whether or not this
kid is Sparks with Cassie Lang and some
Riverdale knockoff on Disney Plus in
2024. you may have noticed in this video
I went into the media business drama
behind all this stuff we don't talk
about that a lot on new rock stars but I
am obsessed with all that stuff it's why
one of my favorite shows on TV right now
is HBO's succession which picks a
fictional version of a company like the
Disney Corporation or really the
rupert-owned fox Corporation I love it
so much and if you would like to see me
break down episodes of that upcoming
Final Season I want to hear from you
comment down below to let us know
whether or not you plan to watch that
season and so if you would watch my
breakdowns I know it's a little
off-brand for new rock stars but I would
love to cover it hey a reminder to
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive and you can support us by grabbing
some merch at nerd riot.shop you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at a
boss follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
thank you